Salut ! Aujourd'hui je ne sais pas dans quelle catégorie je vais ranger cette vidéo.
"Mental Message", "Boost Brain", "Hack Life"...
Je n'en sais rien en fait !
Mais je pense que c'est plus un Hack Life.
Alors c'est parti !
Hack Life !!!
[musique du générique]
Dans la vie il y a quelque chose de
très très désagréable,
c'est quand quelqu'un dit
du mal de vous.
Ça agace un petit peu !
Et la première réaction qu'on a
c'est de vouloir se venger.
Au lieu de vous venger, je vous propose
de guérir la personne
et de vous guérir vous-même
de ce maux là.
Dire du mal sur quelqu'un,
c'est à dire : médire sur quelqu'un,
ça revient à boire du poison , soi-même...
Tu vois ?  Un petit peu de poison...
En espérant que ça fasse du mal
à l'autre personne.
On comprend bien le principe...
Ce n'est pas moi qui aie trouvé
cette métaphore,
elle est issue du livre
"Les accords toltèques",
avec le premier accord:
"Avoir une parole impeccable."
Ce n'est pas évident de s'y tenir.
La plupart du temps quand on est en train
de blablater un petit peu sur quelqu'un,
on se sent un petit peu mal,
un peu coupable de ça.
Alors pourquoi on le fait ?
Très bonne question,
merci de l'avoir posée.
Parler des mauvaises choses que fait une personne, permet d'avoir bonne conscience sur sa propre conduite.
Ça rassure.
Quand on parle des autres,
on ne parle pas de soi-même,
et ça évite de regarder
ses propres soucis.
Et ses propres incohérences des fois...
Parler sur quelqu'un, ça veut dire avoir
un petit peu de pouvoir sur la personne,
ça donne un sentiment de prestige,
un petit peu de pouvoir, un peu de classe !
Mais ce n'est pas classe ça !
Alors si vous voyez quelqu'un
qui fait ça tout le temps,
qui parle sur les autres tout le temps,
sur vous, sur quelqu'un d'autre,
vous pouvez utiliser des petits leviers
psychologiques pour qu'elle arrête ça.
On a le droit d'utiliser du mentalisme
à l'insu de la personne,
pour que la personne aille mieux
malgré elle.
C'est... Ça parait complètement
déontologique comme truc,
mais je pense que ça l'est pourtant...
déontologique.
Là, on est sur embrouille et pipoland...
La première méthode que je vous propose,
c'est celle du virus.
Vous allez infecter la personne qui colporte
des ragots, des rumeurs en permanence.
Et en l'infectant, elle va répandre elle-mêle un virus autour d'elle qui va se retourner contre elle.
Imaginons que vous connaissez quelqu'un
qui dit toujours du mal de vous.
C'est tout à fait possible.
C'est d'ailleurs un truc qui m'a été
dit dans les commentaires,
et cette vidéo est un petit peu
en réponse à ça.
N'hésitez pas à me donner vos thèmes
aussi dans les commentaires.
Je m'y fie et je les note
dans un petit carnet.
Pour infecter la personne
ça va être très simple :
A chaque fois qu'elle va venir vous voir,
et parler avec vous,
vous allez lui raconter des trucs de ouf.
Mais des trucs incroyables,
qui n'existent pas.
Mais des trucs mon gars...
des rumeurs de l'espace !
Ce qui va faire qu'à chaque fois qu'elle va
colporter ses rumeurs un peu ouf,
elle va perdre en crédibilité.
Et puisque qu'on raconte ça pour avoir
un petit peu plus de pouvoir et de prestige,
elle va tout de suite arrêter de parler de vous
et de raconter des rumeurs en règle générale.
Ça va prendre un certain temps.
Mais c'est assez efficace.
Alors évidemment comme vous même vous ne voulez pas passer pour quelqu'un qui raconte des rumeurs,
ne visez personne en particulier.
Ça peut être tout simplement :
"Ah la, la, ! T'as vu l'émission qui a eu hier, sur TF1,
comme quoi Youtube va être payant ? "
Apparemment ça commence la semaine
prochaine. Je suis dégouté...
"Apparemment, cette année il suffira
d'avoir 8/20 pour avoir le BAC.
Je ne sais pas si c'est bien
ou pas bien,
mais en tout cas ça tombe bien pour nous
qui passons le BAC cette année."
Si vous passez le BAC cette année,
sinon cet exemple n'a aucun intérêt.
Vous voyez l'idée : vous lui racontez des
trucs de ouf, mais très généralistes,
qui ne visent pas une personne
en particulier.
Sinon vous êtes vous-même en train
de dire du mal avec vos mots.
Deuxième technique:
Le compliment indirect.
La nourriture de l'égo !
C'est un levier psychologique très efficace pour faire changer une personne : je vous le recommande.
Si vous connaissez quelqu'un qui est toujours
en train de dire du mal des autres, etc.
Faites en sorte que cette personne arrive,
alors que vous êtes en discussion.
Vous, vous savez qu'elle est là, mais elle,
elle ne sait pas que vous savez déjà qu'elle est là.
On voit encore l'idée ?!
En fait, complimentez la, comme si elle était
déjà ce que vous aimeriez qu'elle soit.
Exemple très concret:
Si Julien arrive dans le groupe alors que Julien
répète toujours tout ce qu'on lui dit,
même ce qu'on lui dit de ne pas dire,
il est toujours en train de dire
des rumeurs, des ragots, etc...
Je sais que Julien arrive.
Moi je suis en conversation.
Et là directement je switche
parce que je sais qu'il entend.
Sur un : "Non, Julien c'est vraiment
une personne en qui j'ai une belle estime,
j'ai une belle confiance en lui,
parce que tu vois quand
on lui dit quelque chose,
on sait qu'on peut compter sur lui, quoi...
Évidemment si un jour il me trahissait,
je le vivrai mal,
mais, pour l'instant, c'est
quelqu'un de droit, d'honnête,
il ne dit pas du mal des gens,
c'est cool."
Le fait d'entendre ce
compliment indirect,
ça va faire un travail sur l'égo
et la personne va adapter son comportement
pour être fidèle à l'image
qu'elle croit qu'on se fait d'elle,
et qui lui a valu ces compliments là.
La troisième technique va vous permettre de faire arrêter la personne dans ce processus là.
En tout cas elle arrêtera ce processus de rumeurs et de ragots devant vous et ça l'aidera à arrêter à terme.
Puisqu'elle fait ça, dire du mal des autres,
raconter des ragots, des rumeurs,
ça ne veut pas dire que ce soit en cohérence avec
les valeurs qu'elle pense avoir à l'intérieur d'elle.
Si vous lui faites admettre
ces valeurs là,
elle aura beaucoup de mal
à faire le contraire devant vous,
et même le contraire à terme.
Je reprends l'exemple de mon
Julien de tout à l'heure.
On pourra lui dire par exemple:
Tu ne crois pas, Julien, que ceux
qui disent du mal des autres,
ils font juste ça pour se donner
un petit peu d'importance
et puis pour éviter de regarder ce que
eux font ou ne font pas eux-même ?
Il va forcément répondre dans le côté positif.
Donc il va admettre quelque chose.
Quelque chose que lui fait habituellement.
Donc le fait d'admettre ça,
ça va casser un rituel avec vous,
et espérons à terme,
le rituel avec le reste du monde.
Et enfin une quatrième méthode qui
correspond un petit peu à la première.
La première était de lui inoculer un virus,
et bien là, vous allez inoculer un placébo.
Et celui-ci, il est ouf !
Vous allez voir la personne
et vous lui faites croire que
quelqu'un raconte des ragots sur elle
et fait du commérage sur elle.
Ça fera un truc du style:
"Écoute Julien, je viens te voir parce que
j'ai entendu une rumeur à ton sujet,
alors, ne t'inquiète pas, je ne le dirai
à personne, parce que... voilà...
ça restera entre toi et moi,
mais il y a quelqu'un...
ça m'a était rapporté de quelqu'un
que tu ne connais pas
et je ne veux pas te dire qui c'est,
mais... qui dit que tout le monde dit, que tu dis en permanence du mal des autres...
Que tu balances des rumeurs,
des commérages, et tout...
Et là mon gars, c'est coup compte triple !
D'une : la personne prend conscience que les autres personnes savent qu'elle dit du mal des autres.
De deux : elle comprend le mal
que ça peut faire.
De trois: elle ne peut pas dire que ce n'est pas vrai, puisque c'est vrai que la personne fait ça.
Et de quatre : si elle veut que
cette rumeur la s'arrête,
il faut qu'elle arrête simplement de
colporter des choses qui sont fausses.
Et de parler des autres.
Vous allez pouvoir aider des gens
de votre entourage qui font ça.
En tout cas ne les jugez pas.
Ne leur en voulez pas.
C'est souvent une mécanique qu'ils ont
inscrit dans le temps malgré eux.
Donc la meilleure solution c'est de les aider
à aller un petit peu mieux.
Vous pouvez aussi leur faire lire le premier chapitre des accords toltèques, que je vous recommande.
Je vais vous mettre un lien dans
la description vers ce bouquin.
J'en avais parlé une fois
il y a très longtemps.
Ça a été une révélation pour moi ce livre.
N'hésitez pas à partager cette vidéo.
Merci au fait à tout ceux qui sous-titre,
ça fait un moment que
je ne vous ai pas remercié.
Merci beaucoup !
N'oubliez pas de laisser
un pouce en l'air ! 👍
Il y a une rumeur qui dit que...
vous allez le faire.
Alors j'espère que celle-ci elle est vraie.
N'oubliez pas non plus de vous abonner.
Et rendez-vous ce week-end.
Ciao !
[musique du générique de fin]